it's my pleasure it's my pleasure to
share this presentation with miss
Barbara McNair thank you it is my
pleasure to share anything with you for
the best score of a motion picture that
is not a musical the nominees are and of
the thousand days George
Delarue Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid Burt Bacharach
the Reavers John Williams the secret of
Santa Victoria Ernest gold and the Wild
Bunch
Jerry Fielding what are you announce the
winner cliff no I'm curious but yellow
galaxy
the winner is Burt Bacharach
I'm deeply happy I just can tell you
that there was a knock out picture to
work on and I'm very thrilled great
night thank you
I know how anxious you all are to see
our next commercial but before we do we
have a few awards to bestow we've
already heard the five songs nominated
for the Oscar come Saturday morning with
music by Fred Carlin and lyrics by dory
Previn gene music and lyrics by Rod
McKuen raindrops keep falling on my head
music by Burt Bacharach and lyrics by
Hal David True Grit music by Omer
Bernstein and lyrics by Don Black
and what are you doing the rest of your
life music by Michel Legrand
lyrics by Allen and Marilyn Bergman
thanks the winners are Burt Bacharach
and Hal
this is just marvelous I'm deeply
honored thank you so much I feel the
same way and it's so special two of them
I mean just it's too fantastic uh very
special to me tomorrow morning they'll
be on the breakfast table of our
daughter she's only not even four years
old but that's where she'll look at
these two and she'll know how very
special they are
he made me very very happy I thank you
oh my heart